Want a beautiful garden without breaking
the
bank? Building a DIY trellis is easier
than you
think. In just under an hour, you can
create a stunning structure for your
climbing plants. First, gather your
materials. Wood, nails, and some wire or
twine. Cut your wood to the desired
size. Keep it
simple. Now, start assembling the frame.
Don't worry, it's just a matter of
nailing it together. Once your frame is
ready, add horizontal slats for the
plants to climb. Next, secure it in your
garden. A sunny spot works best.
Finally, plant your climbers at the base
and watch them grow. This not only
beautifies your space, but adds value to
your property, too. Ready to elevate
your garden game? Grab those tools and
let's get building